never notice so sometimes the biggest
stories get the least coverage something
transformative happens that changes
everything and nobody notices what's
happened here for the last two years or
so the rest of us have watched as the
Democratic Party has been utterly
transformed into something totally
different what was once the stodgy
headquarters the center-left
establishment the party of Harry Reid
and Steny Hoyer and guys like that now
looks like a scene out of Burning Man so
far without the nudity starting an
inauguration day Democrats erupted in a
primal scream and they have not yet
stopped yelling everything changed once
Trump got elected celebrities threatened
to abandon this country business leaders
started behaving like political
activists candidates for office embraced
positions so extreme that they rejected
them just months before news reporters
became rigid propagandists and then
weirdest of all comedians lost their
sense of humor here for example is
deeply unfunny comedian Samantha be
lecturing America about Ivanka Trump
last night watch you know Ivanka that's
a beautiful photo of you and your child
but let me just say one mother to
another do something about your dad's
immigration practices you feckless
[Applause]
and low-cut and tell your father to stop
it a dumb person's political harangue
masquerading his comedy
well profoundly sad filmmaker Michael
Moore proclaimed all what you just saw
quote brilliance he called Samantha be a
truth-teller
comedian Billy Eichner wrote on Twitter
he thought B was being quote generous
tonight B is receiving an award from the
television Academy for quote leveraging
the dynamic power of television to
inspire social change well Samantha B
later apologized for that on Twitter
assuming a tweet rates as an apology but
that was that's just temporary she'll
likely be bragging about all of this at
another award ceremony very soon
meanwhile Kathy Griffin who is probably
the single unhappiest person in this
country used her appearance on a daytime
show called the view to launch another
political lecture when White House press
secretary Sarah Sanders responded to
that Griffin wrote a profane tweet
attacking Sarah Sanders blah blah blah
blah blah fu basically what did Kathy
Griffin learn to talk like that well
maybe from US senator Kirsten Gillibrand
of New York who is now regularly using
the f-word in her public appearances
here's one so what about President Trump
hat has he kept any of these promises no
no fundamentally if we are not helping
people we should go
she's not the quickest of US senators
but even so it says something broader
about what's happening in the Democratic
Party's the left is arguing that Trump
is radical how have they responded by
becoming way more radical by going
completely off the edge
they say Trump is vulgar okay so now
they shout profanity on television and
at campaign events amazingly Trump has
somehow convinced the Democratic Party
to completely destroy itself no one ever
says that but it may be the biggest
change he has brought to this country
it's fascinating